conference following our 29th EU Japan
Summit just let me remind you that we
have translation into Japanese English
and French for those following remotely
we're about to publish the statement
that was adopted and I first give the
flow to the president of the European
Council please thank you good afternoon
prime minister kishida diaphumio the
usola it's a pleasure to welcome you
here in Brussels today Japan and EU
Corporation is a strong and positive
server and I would like to send you the
fumio the Prime Minister for your
leadership and personally for your
friendship Japan is one of the EU
strongest allies in Japan is our closest
partner in the indo-pacific region today
we agreed to work for greater security
and prosperity for our people and to
generate more opportunities for our
businesses our shared values are the
best work of our relationship democracy
rule of flow a multilateral cooperation
Japan's support to the people of Ukraine
has been impressive as the current G7
share you have stood resolutely in back
in Ukraine and condemning Russia and
just yesterday in the news we G7 leaders
permitted to Ram pick up our support for
Ukraine and increasing the pressure on
Russia
the EU and Japan are also working
together to bolster peace and security
on the Korean Peninsula no serious
nuclear program in westless missile
tests like the one used to do threaten
Regional and International Security we
condemn this in the strongest possible
terms the indoor Pacific is a vibrant
and ruined region a key player in
shaping wfs in the EU we are stepping up
our engagement with your region
our 27 member states are united on China
recently the European Council reformed
is multifaceted approach both China and
the EU have an interest in a stable and
translative relationship we will engage
to tackle Global challenges but these
are issues that need to be addressed
Level Playing Field reciprocity and a
balanced economic relationship we will
diversify and the risk we appropriate
we'll always promote our values and our
interests today we agree to deepen our
exchanges on all these issues we are
also taking a step forward in our
preparation on security and we agreed to
launch a strategic dialogue that will
also include security and defense and
this will boost our cooperation in areas
like Maritime security or cyber and
hybrid threats
today we also identify key projects that
will help us achieve our green and
digital roles like the hydropower
storage project in Vietnam that will
assist in phasing out toll and driving
forward the green transition
or the northern Corridor project in East
Africa that will improve trade and
transport relativity in that region
economic resilience is a top priority
for both Japan and the EU we agreed to
step up our strategic cooperation to
reinforce our supply chains especially
in critical raw materials like where
Earth
the EU and Japan are also powerful
engines in protecting our planet in the
run-up to 1228 we agreed to cooperate
more in areas that will drive forward
our green transition like Solar Supply
chains offshore winds great technology
and Energy Efficiency and you are also
boosting cooperation on hydrogen
production
ladies and gentlemen just last year
bilateral trade between Japan and the EU
increased more than 13 percent and now
we are building on that momentum we
specifically discuss improving Market
access and today the EU agreed to again
allow the import of products from the
Fukushima region EU fools will also get
better access to Japanese markets this
is another sign of trusting cooperation
dear prime minister kishida the fumio
Japan and the European Union share a
genuine bond that we can be proud of we
are reliable Partners we are reliable
friends for greater peace and Security
in the world and it will continue I
thank you
thank you Mr President Madam president
you have the flu thank you very much
thank you Charles thank you prime
minister
yesterday we were together in Vilnius as
partners at the NATO Summit we discussed
our cooperation in Europe and the
indo-pacific and today we are here
together in Brussels at the EU Japan
Summit a very clear message of
partnership and friendship
we share with Japan the analysis that
from Ukraine to the indo-pacific the
world is one security theater
and also in real news the G7 and Japan's
presidency
and the European Union made very clear
that security commitments to Ukraine are
vital We Stand by Ukraine as we have
done since the beginning of the Russian
aggression
at the same time with our indo-pacific
strategy we are also increasing our
engagement in the region because we know
that indo-pacific security and European
security are indivisible
and I'm pleased that we are launching a
strategic dialogue to coordinate on
these unprecedented challenges to peace
and security
and this includes of course also the
vital topic of Economic Security this is
my first point
we've seen supply chain disruption
caused by the pandemic and Russia's
invasion in Ukraine we've seen cyber
attacks and economic coercion all that
has been a wake-up call for us
Economic Security is of vital importance
and a common concern
we agreed to coordinate on these issues
at the G7 level and now we are launching
a bilateral Dialogue on economic
security as well
as you all know Japan is a front-runner
in this area
we the European Union have just
developed our own Economic Security
strategy
so I believe that we have a lot to gain
from working together on this topic
we share similar dependencies
we both need see the need to de-risk our
supply chains
so one of our objectives is to reduce
over Reliance on a handful of suppliers
many of them based in China
for products that are vital for our
economies
for instance critical raw materials
I'm very pleased that we are concluding
a cooperation Arrangement on raw
materials between the European
commission and Japan
the same goes for semiconductors
and I'm glad that we have also concluded
a memorandum of cooperation on the issue
of semiconductors
it will cover for example monitoring the
supply chains it will cover the very
important aspects of research and of
course the UN
um the the important aspect of advanced
skills for these industry's skilled
Personnel is badly needed
the second point that I want to
emphasize is that we have taken stock of
our economic partnership agreement it is
now enforced since four years
and it is delivering
trade flows have increased by 20 percent
and this despite the covet pandemic
but we also know that we can do much
more
therefore on our side the European Union
side we agreed to lift the remaining
restrictive import measures
that were linked to the Fukushima
accident
we have taken this decision based on
science
and based on the proof of evidence
and based on the assessment of the
international atomic energy agency
and we also agreed to solve several
other trade issues in the course of this
year in particular the access for our
agricultural products to the Japanese
Market
the third topic I want to mention is the
stepping up our cooperation on digital
we have launched our digital partnership
a year ago
since then we have made good progress on
connectivity
for example an exciting project that is
we will deploy an Arctic submarine cable
that delivers high capacity and secure
connections between Europe and Japan
and now we go one step further
we will work on 6G we will work on high
performance Quantum Computing and cyber
security so the whole agenda of the
digital partnership is growing and is
getting more dense and concrete
most importantly we will cooperate on
artificial intelligence this has two
legs of course on one hand we want to
reap its benefits
but on the other hand we also see the
risks and we want to manage the risks
my first point is on cleantech and the
energy transition for that we have our
green Alliance
it's the first screen aligns the
European Union ever concluded here with
Japan and now we are teaming up to
deploy renewable energy
in particular offshore wind and clean
hydrogen in Europe and in Japan
and in parallel we are investing
together in sustainable infrastructure
around the world on the European Union
side this is our investment program you
are well aware of global gateway
and there's a similar investment program
on the Japanese side together
we are showing results for example from
a Hydro power storage project in Vietnam
to railway infrastructure in Indonesia
or to transport corridors in Africa just
to name a few examples
finally I shared our experience with
carbon pricing which is a very good way
to reduce emissions while generating
revenues for the clean energy transition
and it was interesting to hear the plans
on the Japanese side
so in conclusion it was an excellent
Summit with tangible outcomes we need
each other more than ever for our
security and our economic resilience and
we are closer than ever thank you very
much
thank you madam president prime minister
kishida you have the flow
hey um
Koto
animals
foreign
a Mata
jinco Chino AI
um
foreign
Davis
is
Tenkai
[Music]
hey
foreign
events
thank you prime minister for your
remarks we'll first be taking a couple
of questions from the Japanese media and
we have a question from TV Asahi yes
please
um